let's just begin for people that may not
be familiar with your career
and how it just you know expanded into
the world of professional sports
in basketball you were drafted into the
nba just take us up from
who you are and how you got there well i
got drafted in 1996
i attended the university of kentucky um
and
at 19 years old i got drafted number six
by the celtics and
beginning my journey into the nba and
was fortunate enough to play uh
13 years in the nba three-time all-star
uh played majority of my years in boston
which was eight um but
won a championship in 1990 i mean in
2006 with shaquille o'neal and dwyane
wade
so that's unbelievable you felt on top
of the world i bet oh yeah
i felt that like the world was uh you
know it wasn't mine at the as you would
want to say but um it was great um i had
a great career i would never
take it back it was something that i
enjoyed and and
i always remember the rest of my life
all right so you get drafted
do you remember the big check do you
remember the first time you got a big
check
yeah my first checkup you know because
you don't get paid to november
uh when you get drafted in june you
don't get paid to november so my first
big check um i took it and
purchased a home uh for my mom okay so
um
it was big um i was able to work out a
negotiation with the team to be able to
get
a big lump sum of my money up front
which usually doesn't happen but
i was the grace of god i was able to do
that and i purchased my mama home
okay so you buy your mother a home and
you also help out other family members
don't you and now you have a lot of very
new friends
yeah i'm i'm the oldest of six um so
it's four boys two girls
um i have two daughters of my own
congratulations
and then obviously you know i got family
and friends who i'm very close with that
grew up with me
um so i usually ran with about eight to
nine guys that kind of grew up in the
same
neighborhood and things with me so i
actually wanted them to see
the same lifestyle that i that i was
enjoying so what would be an example of
something that you did
at that younger age that you look back
on now and say you just
can't believe you spent the money doing
that i would say
a lot of exotic cars jewelry um that i
did
i was a kind of car fetish when i was
very young i had five or six different
cars but i had the most expensive cars
when
we talking about mint leaf beverly's
maybach's
mercedes-benz so a lot of high-end
things i was into designer watches you
know rolex's
no timeless pieces that you can have
forever so i was into those type of
things
all right that was what you were into
but you also paid for things
for friends didn't you you went places
you went to vegas tell us about that
aspect of it well we went on lavish
trips i mean we would go on vacation
together we would go to
cancun we go to puerto rico we would go
you know different places and throughout
the united states
and i would travel with a big group of
guys i would travel with eight to ten
people with me and pay for their flights
hotel rooms
eating on the road so you have those
combinations of things you know we used
to have
real big deals at the end of those trips
all right now you're getting paid
because you're playing
professional basketball is there anybody
on the team
is there any business manager that says
wait a minute antoine
you know you're a great guy but the
money is not going to last forever
anybody try to sit down and have that
conversation well i had a financial
advisor a guy that was handling my money
but as any
young arrogant kid i didn't want to
listen to them i kind of took things in
my own
my own manner and made sure that i did
what i wanted to do with my money so
i was advised a little bit but i
definitely took things in my own manner
just through my own
um being my own ego all right so you
decide what
that this is the life for you you keep
spending the money
but then something happens the money
runs out
what happened what's the combination of
things i think one what we just talked
about the lifestyle
um i lost a significant portion of money
gambling
i used to go to vegas and gamble um i
lost the bulk of my money
um investing in real estate um in which
in 2007
2008 we went through the recession i'm
sure this is a worldwide thing that we
all went through
and i got caught up in that web and that
was that ultimately ended um
the bulk of my wealth so you add those
three things together um they played a
huge part in me losing all my finances
okay so you take those things those
three things but now you take this idea
that you want to share the story you
want to complete it because
you're at a personal bankruptcy and
you've got a movie
called gone in an instant tell us about
the film well i wanted to come out and
basically try to teach guys not just
necessarily athletes but just people in
general about having a lot of money
sometimes every
different people come into wealth in
different different areas so i wanted to
share my
going through bankruptcy i kind of got
an opportunity to do that and see
all the mistakes that i made so i want
to share those things but also tell my
story so people can see it as a learning
example
um creating a foundation for finance
literacy
um i have a book coming out at the
beginning of the year to talk about some
of the trials and tribulations that i
also went through and that so people
can understand what's going on in life
and make sure they do the right thing so
hopefully it can hit home for everybody
don't necessarily have to be an athlete
all right well i'm glad you mentioned
books because we'd like to get to know
you a little bit
more and i'd like to know for example
what is the the last book that you
have read what's the the most current
for you
think rich and grow the black choice i
was just reading it
i'm just kind of learning about finances
going through a different
going through my process i thought it
was a great book for me to read
to kind of help me want to you know get
myself back together so
i'm not a huge book reader so that book
was brought to me and told me i should
read it so i read it and it's been
very helpful and it spoke to you oh
definitely i hit hit home just with
a lot of financial situations things
that i don't i never thought about when
i was playing and when i had a lot of
money
all right now when you were growing up
while you were playing who was your idol
magic johnson magic johnson was my idol
obviously i wanted to be like him on the
court
i was a guy that was very tall for my
age so i grew to be six nine he was a
six nine point guard
but also what he went through i mean the
way he was so courageous and he came out
when he got hiv virus
i had the unique opportunity in 96 to be
able to be around magic a lot and
playing this charity game so
he was just one guy that i always looked
up to